let's continue working out the
pronunciation system of Latin American
Spanish rewind a bit to the concept of
complementary distribution where
different allophones of a phoneme show
up in different contexts I use the word
context to give you an indication of the
surrounding phonemes the other sounds
that surround that allophone the normal
term for that is an environment sounds
don't exist on their own they exist in a
specific environment sometimes that
environment changes the sound here are
some examples of complimentary
distribution in Spanish in Paris in
Britannia in Korea in Graham Britannia
in Espania yong-pan No so we see three
different allophones of a single phoneme
N 1 mm 1 mm and 1 hmm we can account for
these allophones by discussing their
environments we can say that mmm occurs
between an E and a P or between an E and
a B we can say that the egg sound occurs
between E and K or a and G and we see
just the plain n sound between any two
vowels or at the beginning of a word or
at the end of a word this gives us some
understanding of how and when to
reproduce these allophones and
complementary distribution but then we
can move on to make more concise
generalizations using our understanding
of phonetics P and B are both bilabial
plosive we can say that the phoneme n
shows up as M before a bilabial plosive
P is a voiceless bilabial plosive and b
as a voiced bilabial plosive similarly
cut and gaw are both velar plosive we
can say that n shows up as that Eng
sound before a velar plosive whether
it's the voiced velar plosive gut or the
voiceless cut and then it seems to show
up as n anywhere else so between vowels
or before after silence in other words
at the beginning or end
word now that you've gained a more
intelligent appreciation for the
environments where the allophones of n
show up in Spanish you can move to
creating a rule that describes how one
sound becomes another sound in those
environments so we can say that n
becomes an M sound between a vowel and a
bilabial plosive we noticed that in our
examples we would write such a rule like
this n becomes M in the environment
where it is preceded by a vowel and
followed by a consonant with the
features bilabial and plosive which can
be voiced or voiceless as we saw will
look for other words where the phoneme n
would show up between a vowel and a
bilabial plosive to check this rule what
we'll find is that the rule holds but
we'll also try to find counter examples
that would force us to modify this rule
for the sake of accuracy
one such counter example would be if the
phoneme n ever shows up as an M before a
sound that is not a bilabial or applo's
it unfortunately will eventually run
into examples that break the rule in
just that way M Francia seems to follow
our rule except that the sound following
the allophone M of the phoneme n is not
a bilabial plosive it's a labial dental
fricative so we need to find a way to
strengthen our rule first notice that
both fricatives and plosives are op
strengths meaning that you highly
restrict the airflow when you make them
also both labial dentals and by labels
are labial sounds so named because they
involve the lips what if we broaden our
rule a bit the rewritten rule would look
like this n becomes M in the environment
where it is preceded by a vowel and
followed by a labial up straight
there you have a stronger rule that
seems to apply throughout Spanish
I hope you now have a better
understanding of rules and environments
and the basics of phonology more general
you